[Applause]
and to our top story at six abortion is
a constitutionally guaranteed right here
in Nevada but will the Silver State
extradite those being prosecuted in
other states well that is the debate
front and center as the Nevada state
house right now we do thank you for
joining us here at six o'clock I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus now
proponents say Senate Bill 131 protects
patients and providers opponents say it
clears the way for more human
trafficking Ryan Matthey live now in
studio to break it all down Ryan yeah
Brian Denise it's a fairly short bill
Senate Bill 131 here if passed would
prevent retaliation against providers
who perform abortions here on people who
don't live here it also limits the
governor's ability to extradite those
patients back to their home state if
it's not legal over there it's not
passed yet and critics say there's a lot
of changes needed before it is
we have neighbor states that are going
backwards Maria Theresa liberman paragua
sat in the grand Sawyer State Building
Monday morning Senate Bill 131 listening
as state lawmakers debated in Carson
City she's deputy director of battleborn
progress a self-proclaimed Progressive
non-profit that supports sb-131 a
proposed Senate bill that seeks to
protect abortion access in Nevada
for those traveling outside the state to
get them it is not enough to Simply
promise that you're not going to do that
you're not going to prosecute that
you're not going to participate in other
states Prosecuting we need to have
something in the books projections for
both patients and providers it's
restricting too much for the boards the
governor and the agencies the
restrictive for others concerns of Kelly
Quinn former Nevada and Clark County
Health regulator the bill would prohibit
the Governor from extraditing out of
state patients back to their home state
simply because they got an abortion and
state agencies would be unable to assist
in certain out-of-state investigations
involving those who illegally got an
abortion back home a uh sex trafficker
say could bring their minor children to
Nevada who have gotten pregnant and even
come here posing as a parent but you
can't ask the question if they are or
not and have certain procedures done
and then they're right back into the sex
trafficking industry
now important to know people already
come here from out of state to get
abortions Nevada Senate Majority Leader
Nicole canizarro says this bill does not
or does nothing to Shield people who
partake in either child abuse or human
trafficking Denise so Ryan one final
note here this bill would codify a 2022
executive order signed by former
governor sisalak and it protected these
kinds of out-of-state patients following
the Roe v Wade overturn on his website
Governor Lombardo meantime refers to
himself as pro-life though ensures he
will make sure that contraceptive
contraceptives I should say are
accessible